sur ce plateau le général morillon qui
était récemment encore commandant de la
force onu pour la bosnie et qui est bien
placé pour parler du désarroi pour ne
pas dire du désespoir des habitants des
différentes régions une manne censée
être protégés par les nations unies vous
voyez sur ces images on mars 93
le général morillon s'était rendu lui
même à ses valises à encercler et affamé
par les serbes
c'est vraiment ça qui est finalement
tombé il y a un petit peu plus de deux
semaines
mon général bonsoir c'est leur ai dit ça
j'ai pas biya ce peut-être est-ce que
toutes les enclaves vont tomber les unes
après les autres comme des dominos et là
dessus c'est quand même les la chute de
srebrenica et celle de zepa était
prévisible dans la mesure où je crois
que les bosniaques eux mêmes n'ont pas
vraiment défendu donc c'est tout à fait
différent à biatch ya tout un corps
d'armée d'ailleurs quelle farce était
beaucoup plus légères g paille et a
sabré nietzsche acabit atx biatch la
zone protégée elle même c'est la ville
et les combats se déroulent assez loin
de la ville actuellement pour répondre à
votre question je ne vois pas de menace
immédiate sur la zone protégée de
billautshow sur ses habitants alors le
sénat américain a voté hier ou
avant-hier la lgv est unilatérale de
l'embargo il vous allez bientôt à la
washington pour tenter de plaider auprès
des idées raemerich 1 de revenir sur
cette décision
là je suis habité par un groupe franco
américain de réflexion stratégique c'est
un voyage profite m'en priver je vais
m'efforcer effectivement de convaincre
les américains que ce serait la plus
mauvaise des solutions parce que je
crois que c'est ça s'accompagnera on l'a
dit du retrait de la force onu et que ce
serait une catastrophe
la batterie notre civilisation mais mais
pour la bosnie elle même l'objectif de
mladic est sûrement le retrait la fois
produit est immédiatement après manquera
pas de s'attaquer tout de suite à
sarajevo
je rappelle quand même que lorsque j'y
suis arrivé en octobre 92 tous les
augures annoncé la chute imminente de
sarajevo et que la présence ma présence
symbolique avec quelques jeunes au coeur
de la ville à ce moment-là à feuchy a
été dans ce contexte la constitution de
la force de réaction rapide vous paraît
une bonne chose d'une utilité si c'est
ce que moi même j'avais demandé et tous
mes successeurs après moi c'est à dire
un moyen dans ce pays de se faire
respecter
pour dans ce type de conflit avec ce
type
deux combattants pour être respecté il
faut être fort et nous n'étions pas
assez fois la force de réaction rapide
qui vient de se mettre en place et dont
on assure actuellement le renforcement
avec des canons de 155 lorsque vous avez
vu tout à l'heure aura les moyens je
l'espère et c'est la dernière chance de
redonner à l'ensemble de la force
sa raison d'être c'est à dire sa liberté
d'action
dernière question général morillon que
vous inspire ce qu'a déclaré tout à
l'heure à de vannes cardy que leader des
serbes bosniaques qui a proclamé l'état
de guerre en république serbe
alors cette programmation a été faite à
la suite de l'offensive droite dans à la
frontière de la boucherie à l'intérieur
de la bosnie pour soulager 5e quoi
bosniaque mais surtout pour couper le
corridor qui est vital pour les serbes
de krajina et qui relie knin leur
capital à
la ville de banias luca tenue par les
serbes de bosnie donc ceux ci expliquent
cette réaction
puisqu'on parle de karadzic aujourd'hui
je voulais simplement dire que sa
condamnation par la cour de sûreté par
la cour internationale de justice et
celle du général mladic nous
l'attendions tous et que pour autant il
faut peut-être pas diaboliser les serbes
dans leur ensemble
de quoi que les serbes dans leur
ensemble
ce sont des hommes qui de bonne foi
croyez que mladic les conduisait à la
croisade
pour chauffer la chrétienté contre une
menace d'invasion par l'islam et que ce
qui s'est passé à sa moniteur plus
traitées comme du bétail à mon prêt doit
montrer l'autorité morale religieuse
politique de la serbie que c'est sur la
voie de la barbarie quand les entraîne
et qui n'est peut-être pas trop tard
pour éviter d'être placé l'ensemble du
peuple serbe au banc de l'humanité comme
l'allemand l'a été merci général bien
merci jeunes est un maillon pour ce
commentaire